sometimes
testing testing that sounds all right
thank you beginners era sorry
good morning everyone and thank you for
coming along to the planning meeting
today 22nd of November 2022. it's just
gone 10 o'clock
um first of all I'd like to take us
through standard notes just to start
Where We Are
um if the fire alarm rings please do
leave the room by the nearest door and
we will be assembling in the car park
hopefully it won't be raining can I ask
if you have a mobile phone with you if
you could switch it to silent please or
turn it off
um
would members please note that if you're
not in the meeting to hear the entire
debate on the item then you cannot vote
on the item can I also ask that if you
do wish to speak if you raise your hands
and make sure you keep them raised until
the microphone comes to you just so that
the gentleman can find you up
please keep all your points short do not
interrupt when someone else is speaking
and obviously do use the microphones
okay
um we will be having a recorded vote
today
by roll call which my colleague Sarah
Sawyer will be
um
managing as it were from that point of
view so can I turn to the first item on
the agenda please the apologies
we we have apologies
from councilor Nuttall Nutley Hayes
Parker and Piet and councilor connet is
a substitute for councilor Nutley
thank you for that and the next item on
the agenda uh the minutes of the meet
last meeting
are you happy for me to sign them as a
true record could we have proposed a
sector go to the vote please
for for the minutes for the minutes yeah
yeah we do need a proposer and a
seconder but I'm asking if you're happy
for that if you could either propose and
second and we can go to the vote
thank you
thank you council do you Hearst a second
can I see a show of hands please
and any against
any abstentions
thank you that's Carriage yeah thank you
next item Declarations of Interest any
members have a declaration of interest
at uh for this item that we have before
us
I don't be noted and I'm not on this
committee please I have been before it's
come to a full Council for the positions
to be readjusted that I have been if
you're right removed from this committee
or whether it's justifiable in the
Constitution or not I'm not altogether
sure but uh I am that's the reason that
I'm not on this committee anymore and I
think it should be noted okay Council
Clarence thank you obviously you're
staying at the committee as you're
already here so I appreciate you you're
making that point thank you
um I would like to declare the interest
that I am a award member for the item
before us
um but I I am going to be speaking on
the item
thank you and voting
any other Declarations of interest from
my members no
okay
we don't have any public participation
today
um so
I think really we need to take ourselves
to the planning applications for
consideration however I have just
noticed on my notes I would just like to
clarify that councilor Jeffrey you are
here today and I'd just like to confirm
for the record that you're not related
to the Jeffrey family who are the owners
of the the property that we are or the
land that we are looking at today
distant
sorry I think I am but very distant
yeah it was whether you should take that
as an interest from that point of view
but I just thought I I did think about
that chairman but it's so distant that
okay I hope you don't mind me raising up
the best thing to do that's fine yeah
thank you
okay
um so can I um hand over to our planning
officer Anna Holloway
pleased to take us through this item
21.02674 major segmentation Farm in
dawlish please
foreign
this is an application for area three of
housing allocation da2 at dawlish
the application includes 201 houses of
which 29 would be affordable including
21 affordable rent which includes two
disabled Bungalows and eight shared
ownership
which equates to 14 affordable housing
however the council would give a waiting
for the disabled Bungalows are set out
in the update sheet so the officer
opinion is that it is actually close to
the 15
which is the amount set out in the
viability report there's also 33
retirement properties which includes 11
bungalows
The Proposal also includes open space
including
allotments and Community Orchard and
also a combined leap and neep play Space
informal play space and
green and blue
infrastructure with the suds adjacent to
shusterton Brook
the scheme also would deliver the Link
Road that's where it should be
through the da2 allocation you can see
there the area four this is the site
currently being constructed by persimmon
on the Langdon Hospital site that's from
the
Sainsbury's roundabout and
to a persimmon will be building the road
through to the Bridge Landing point the
County Council has planning consent
separately for the bridge over Justin
Brook
and also hip funding for the delivery of
the road through to the boundary area
too that's the yellow line on the on the
plan there
area two there is outline consent for
and there are currently two Reserve
matters applications in for housing on
area two that is separate from from the
application today which is purely for
full Planning Commission for area three
you can see that the location plan
um the site at the moment is accessed
through the blue land
but following consent this access would
come from the north
um via that bridge and then link into
area two to the South
so the um you can see there the
north to south Link Road through the
site
and also an access through to the east
which would link through to area five
and on the western edge you can see the
green infrastructure which would run
alongside Justin Brook
and that shows the allotments play areas
and
um
the other well the suds and the other
green infrastructure
I think that probably shows the green
infrastructure a bit better you can see
the orchard there just above the play
Space
so the proposal includes a mix of
housing
as I said before we're doing we do have
11 retirement Bungalows and two disabled
Bungalows within this scheme
we have some of the
housing types there
and these are the site photos from the
taken at the site visit which happened
on Friday
so in that photo you can see Langdon
Hospital site in the distance there
and as we move around you can see the
persimmon scheme and then the red rose
scheme which is built out next to
Sainsbury's
let me swing around in a moment so here
we have the area where the green
infrastructure would be
um with the trees there along shutterton
Brook
and we can see here some of the existing
housing developments have taken place
um within the earlier phases with the
kafana home scheme
and that has area two in the in the
distance there connecting into that
um
already built housing scheme
so the officer recommendation remains
are set out in the committee report for
approval subject number of obligations
and conditions
but with the amendment to the affordable
housing set out in the update sheet and
plus a condition for the details of the
connection with area 5 to be approved
prior to commencement of the relevant
phase that is in in combination with the
obligation already in the recommendation
regarding the um the connection to area
five
thank you chair
thank you Anna
um so I know we have Ward members who
would like to speak on this item I don't
know who would like to go first but I'd
like to call the board members to to
speak at this point please
if you would like to come up whoever
decides to come up first if you'd like
to come to the desk here with the
microphone
thank you councilor pedrick
this development was included in the
local plan approximately 10 years ago
the site is defined as area three of
five areas the total size of these areas
are approximately 35 hectares of land
which is located northwest of secmayton
Lane and expected to deliver 860 homes
with a target of 25 affordable homes
today's application is for 201 new homes
I'm disappointed that the site will
deliver a much reduced percentage of
affordable homes I understand that the
developer has carried out a viability
exercise
justifying the reduced number of
affordable homes
and our officers consider the outcome of
the viability study to be acceptable
would the officers please explain why
the application is not viable to deliver
25 affordable homes
construction of 250 homes on an adjacent
site is already underway and another
adjacent site will be expected to
accommodate 400 new homes
the current plan requires the developers
to provide for vehicle access through
the developments between the a379 Exeter
Road and Elm Grove Road including
supported bus service cycle lanes and
footpaths
the new road is described as a link Road
which has been much acclaimed residents
are enthusiastic about its delivery
the new road will access access the 860
new homes together with at least 1 000
homes that have already been occupied
I have concerns about the suitability
and efficiency of the Link Road
which will be just six meters wide
I understand from County Council that
the new road will not be marked with
double yellow lines
a large number of dwellings defined
within this application will have
garages and driveways that will be
accessed from the new Link Road
it is inevitable that some residents
will choose to park on the highway near
their homes which will complicate and
impede the flow of traffic along this
new Road
as a result large Vehicles buses and
lores will have to weave in and out of a
large number of cars parked on both
sides of the highway
this could seriously impact on the
safety of pedestrians and other Road
users a solution can be easily achieved
by yellow lining the total length of the
new Link Road
I would urge the committee to consider
this
as a member of the patient Forum group
at the local doctor's surgery
I know that the surgery is already very
stretched with new patients and there is
not sufficient doctors and other medical
staff to service the needs of the
patients already on their registers
the Barton surgery is running at more
than full capacity and adding more
patience is only going to make the
situation worse thank you
can I ask officers are you going to
respond to these points hopefully
um all together at the end of all the
speakers or did you wish to to speak as
we go
as with suit you chair I think it will
probably be good while the questions are
in our minds if that if that would be a
bit okay we could go thank you thank you
um in terms of the viability
um I think that's the first Point Race
the viability report uh it was actually
undertaken by an independent viability
assessor
um and uh reviewing the
the applicants
um
the applicant's information they
submitted for that this is a
resubmission of an application and the
original application actually came in
with five percent affordable housing
which was refused by officers as being
insufficient so the the viability report
that's been carried out the viability
assessment was done by an independent
assessor as required by our our policy
[Music]
um
in terms of the the Link Road through
the site this has been reviewed by the
County Council as the local highways
Authority and they haven't raised any um
concerns in terms of the safety of
what's proposed uh the
um the design of that road is
um for a maximum that as you'd expect of
30 miles per hour
that's what it's been designed to and
it's seen as a
a main road but through a residential
area so it's it's not a
it's not expect to be like a 40 mile an
hour road where you'd have clear ways
through there in terms of the yellow
lines
um that would be a matter if if required
for the local Highway Authority but none
have proposed at this stage in terms of
local doctor surgery the as with the
other
areas here there is a an obligation
proposed for 400 pounds per dwelling
towards the local surgery
um so that that's within this proposed
within the section 106 for this site but
it was also required for area four and
area two
um which is which they're looking to
obviously commence on they have outline
consent for and they're looking to
commence on shortly so that would be
expected to deliver some additional
funding for the local surgery
um I don't think there's any other
points unless Ros wants to come back in
on anything
thank you chair okay thank you we will
move on to the next Ward member
um councilor Wrigley
uh thank you chair I'd like to endorse
and agree with councilor pedrick's uh
comments
and add to that dentists
dentists are a massive problem we
already have many people in dawlish who
cannot find a dentist which is common in
a lot of places but the contribution
towards the Barton surgery will not
actually help us in terms of dentists so
that is something we do need to consider
please
and as County councilor for the area I
will take up the issue of yellow lines
in that space and the design of that
road and Champion the suggestion that
councilor Patrick has made because I
think that's a good one
firstly I'd like to thank the officers
for the work they've done on this this
is a
section of five large developments
around all ish none of which are
particularly welcome and dawlish it is a
huge increase to the size of the town
without sufficient increase in the
facilities the infrastructure of the
town and it's not a piece of planning
that I feel we will be proud of in the
long run as we see more and more
problems on the main a379 especially
through starcross that whole area is not
fit for purpose as
modern my former conservative colleagues
of this Council has always said and I
will continue to say
we have more problems with
infrastructure coming from this however
I feel a good job has been done with a
site that has to come forward
you will have noticed from tramping
around the field it is a very wet and
boggy field it is notoriously water
sodden already I'm very pleased that the
bridge is coming forward through the
county and that the Link Road is being
delivered up to the Gatehouse site at a
very early stage to ensure that the
construction traffic goes through
however I am still concerned and I don't
see sufficient details worked out in
advance yet on the drains and the
drainage both foul and runoff from the
site
Southwest water have talked of a
strategic sewer to connect this area I
don't see mention of that in this
document and I would like to ask the
officers to ensure that conversations
with Southwest water continue for the
Strategic sewer solution
you may have noticed there's been a
large amount of Works delivering a new
storage tank at the bottom of this site
just off the persimmon site some two
million pounds putting in that storage
tank of two or three years ago
which was an attempt to stop sewage
flooding from the sekmaton drain segment
Lane drain
that was taking the sewage from the
thousand houses that had already been
built down one single six-inch pipe
that resulted in people having sewage in
their Gardens for a period of five years
until we managed to get the Solutions in
place I do not want that to happen again
and we have seen developers and their
representatives already looking at that
drain to try to connect into it possibly
not from this area but I want to make
sure that the Strategic sewer solution
is implemented
and is not left late in the day please
I'm disappointed with the affordable
housing numbers similar to councilor
Patrick I understand viability and I
welcome the Bungalows even though they
hit viability I welcome the Bungalows on
this site I am very disappointed that
these are quoted at affordable rent and
not at Social rent current policies I
think imply they should be social rent
so I would like that if that can be
checked and looked into please to ensure
that this see if this could be social
rent rather than affordable rent
the description in the link of the Link
Road in the conditions I think might
need some slight adjustment
for example in 2D
I think it's 2D it talks about the
delivery
of the
Bridge area land
and we know that Devon County are
intending to build the link road all the
way up to the area to boundary
so I suspect this should say the land
required for the link road all the way
through to area to should be delivered
at the beginning rather than waiting for
it so it's just a matter of detail there
checking if that could be checked please
I'm pleased the area 5 link has been
mentioned I haven't seen the additional
document I didn't see what was in there
for that so I'd like some more
description on that because we know the
area five have been appealing the
decision I've been appealing the need to
put in a connection and want to come out
onto secmate and Lane that has been
happily turned down in support of this
Council which I was very pleased to see
so well done that's a good call there
but that area five link is vital to
ensure that SEC mate and Lane which is
largely now pedestrian housing access
and cycles and a main link for those
thousand new houses for people to walk
down to Sainsbury's that should not have
additional traffic from the 24 35 houses
however many end up on area five so that
is vitally important that is insured and
I presume that is within the 50 house
limit
so I'd like it confirmed that that area
5 Link Road link which will not be built
by Devon so they say
will be within the 50 house
occupation limit please
allotments
the allotments are very welcomed
especially if the land is so wet it
should be good growing land which would
be fantastic I am slightly concerned
there is no mention in here of the
management of those allotments
I would like it to be stipulated please
that at the very least a conversation is
had with the Town Council so that it is
clear that those allotments are for the
town of dawlish and not just for people
on this particular site I would not like
to see the allotments managed by the
management company of this site and see
them
unused due to more allotments than you
have people within the area
so I would like some stipulation on the
management of the allotments and also
the community Orchard please because
Community orchards are particularly
difficult if they are left once the
developer puts them in they're then left
they're abandoned and then somebody
scrubs them out because they don't know
what they're about and what they're for
so the ongoing management of both of
those I think we need to put more in the
conditions please
the timings of some of the conditions
are not clear
some of them are talking about
pre-commencement some of them don't
mention
uh what's happening there
um and my other big uh bug bear on these
developments that turn Fields into
building sites are the ongoing treatment
of the hedges
I know you have details of boundary
treatments
however on previous developments we've
had sites that asked for the hedgerows
to be protected during development
but then what's happened is that the
developer has sold the individual bits
of hedge with the houses without any
conditions on what they can do with them
the house owner then quite naturally
chops it down and puts a fence in place
I would not like to see that happen
through this site so can we ensure that
the heteros are protected please post
development as well as during
development and conveyancing does not
sell them to the individual house owners
and similarly the management of this
site in the future needs to ensure that
those hedgerows are maintained in
perpetuity please
just one final thing on the link Road
this road will of course connect up to
our famous kahei way
let's not make that mistake again please
so whilst the lining of the Link Road I
think will now align on the plans it may
not have always done so and I see there
is a condition about levels on the site
can we pay particular and very close
attention please to the fact that the
roads must line up both
horizontally and vertically
and finally post boxes
I know it's not within the planning
authorities remit to determine where
post boxes are there is a universal
obligation for new housing to provide
post boxes if you are less than a mile
away or more than a mile away from a
post box
the closest post box I can think to this
site is Saint Mary's cottages
which is not walkable to from this site
so whilst it is not within the remit I
would like guidance from this authority
to actually suggest that the developer
considers putting at least one post box
the Thousand homes that Council of
pedrick mentioned there is not one
single post box on that entire estate
so it would be extremely helpful to have
one put into this estate please
and I think that's my list
so whilst I'm asking for the conditions
to be tightened up I think this is
something that we probably need to go
through but make sure it happens in a
nicely controlled and uh more acceptable
way thank you very much
thank you
I don't think both my fellow Ward
members have left me with very much to
to say on on this
um I think I've been ticking off items
on my list that I was going to raise
um so I will reserve a few comments for
the site Inspection Team and ask for
other members of the site Inspection
Team who are present if they had
anything they wanted to to say
do they need to come up to no no no
that's fine okay I'm happy to speak now
yeah okay okay thank you very much yes
uh I mean as we all know this this this
this development has been embraced in
our local plan for over 10 years
um and during the site visit it was
obvious to me that it ticks all the
boxes with the exception of the um
affordable homes only 15 rather than 25
percent I do have a few concerns however
but I would prefer to wait until later
in the meeting and I can address those
with with the members if I may please
thank you thank you
cancer Bradford did you wish to speak on
this
thank you
um I did go on the site visit and I'm
also aware that a lot of work has gone
into this report for the application
and yes I understand it's in local plan
however the site's only a relatively
short distance from the accessory
special protection area and ramsar site
I'm sure most people know what a ramsar
site is but I'll I'll repeat it a
dedicated ramsar site is a wetland of
international importance
originally focused on birds but extended
and recognized that a Wetlands is an
ecosystem and it's extremely important
for biodiversity conservation in general
and for the well-being of human
communities
I don't like the word mitigation
mitigation just makes something severe a
little less severe and all I can see in
this plan are contributions for this and
contributions for that
greater horseshoe bats and cell buntings
are being poorly served in this plan
as it stands there will be a nut
detrimental effect the mitigation
proposals which are being put forward
are subject to a high degree of
uncertainty as to their efficacy
bats do not like light and one of the
ways to get rid of bats is plenty of
light it cannot be assumed that
mitigation will be effective
planting trees doesn't make it okay to
fail mature ones it takes a lot of years
for trees to grow and the planting of
new trees and hedgerows will not provide
the same ecosystem benefits as
established trees
it was extremely wet underfoot on the
site visit and I have noted that the
environment agency did object to the
proposal and did not think it would be
safe from flooding over its lifetime and
could also increase the flood risk
elsewhere
I believe this plan is flawed and we
should take notice of the ward members
and the Town Council I think we're being
very short-sighted developing all of our
agricultural land a lot of things have
changed dramatically since this local
plan was put in place 10 years ago
and I think we as a council should be
able to change too
thank you
thank you very much I've realized I
haven't given officers a chance to to
come back on um Ward members notes I do
apologize
um if you would be kind enough to to
pick up that button now sorry
thank you chair
um
on a few of those points raised in terms
of the dentists we hadn't received a
request for that the um the obligations
were
um
was set out in the adopted SPD
development framework for this site
which include obviously the contribution
to Barton surgery
um and I don't believe there was ever
ever a request for a contribution
towards the dentist there
um so we wouldn't have a reason to
impose an obligation on this without any
sort of planning basis for that
in terms of the we've had some comments
made about the uh the drainage and the
um the environment agency's objection
after we received that objection we had
a meeting with the developer the
environment agency Devon County Council
and teambridge's own drainage engineer
to discuss this site to come up with a
suitable drainage strategy and following
that we got we received amended details
for that and both the environment agency
and the um
and county is the lead local flood
Authority withdrew their objections and
have no objection subject to a number of
conditions which are proposed to be
included which to engage within the
officer recommendation
so the there is no current environment
agency objection to this site in terms
of foul drainage Southwest water were
consulted on this and haven't raised an
objection to it they say they can make
the connection uh so from a planning
application point of view we wouldn't
have a reason to refuse this application
on that basis
the in terms of Link Road to area
area five the SPD so it's an adopted
document sets that out but that would
happen at the 100th home not the 50th
which is why that is the the obligation
as proposed the management of the
allotments and the Orchards would also
be covered by the planning obligation
um so we would expect details of the
ongoing management and maintenance
responsibilities
um if uh we can include a a request
within that that it's
um it can be they could offer it to the
Town Council but we couldn't require
that to take place
um
obviously if we can clarify that that's
for local people if there's a specific
area that the members would like to see
that there's allotments being available
for
um whether or not it's dawlish town area
itself or a wider area then we can look
at including that within the section
106.
in terms of the uh The Wider kind of the
ongoing
um management and maintenance of the
open space which should include any
hedgerows which are in the um
which within the green infrastructure
areas
that that would be dealt with via the
planning obligations the management of
that area but also through the proposed
Lemp so that's the landscape and
ecological management plan
um
this is located close to the accessory
and the ramsar site and dawlish Warren
sac and it's also within the landscape
connectivity zone for the great
horseshoe bats and there are there is
one cell bunting
um
habitat on the on the site
this has been reviewed in detail by the
council's biodiversity officer and a an
appropriate assessment has been
undertaken and a consultation on that
has gone to Natural England and subject
to the uh the requirements of that
of that approach assessment there is no
objection from either the biodiversity
officer or Natural England on the
proposals for this they considered the
proposals will mitigate the impact
so there wouldn't be a likely
significant effect
on the European sites
um so that's kind of covered a lot of
points I think I've probably picked up
on everything
um one I can remember is post boxes
sorry
um
there isn't a planning basis for us to
ask for a post box on this site we can
obviously
ask the developer to to look at
providing one but it's not a planning
basis for doing so
okay thank you for for clarifying that
and I'm sorry about the uh
calling you on at the right time
um I'm just going to make a couple of
statements going back to the site
Inspection Team
um from my perspective as I went on the
on on that
um visit
um and then we'll draw that part of the
the meeting to the close if that's okay
um
it's really difficult you visit a
um a
landscape site green and Rolling Hills
on a sunny day and you're looking at a
site of a placement of 200 plus houses
roads Etc so it's quite emotive
maybe it would have been better if it
was raining I'm not sure
um
the site as has been said is allocated
in the local plan I do feel the offices
have worked extremely hard
um to get the conditions that they have
I'm I am a little disappointed in the
fact that we're not policy compliant in
the 25 affordable for the plot but I am
very heartened by the fact that we have
Bungalows and two disabled Bungalows and
Bungalows that have got
um
permitted development rights
um withdrawn so they will stay as
Bungalows there is a demand in the area
for those
um so that is something that does
actually add the extra weight to the um
to the percentage I think it was 15
um
um I will obviously carry on listening
to the debate
um and the report I've listened to the
reports and consider my
um
decision
um
yeah as everyone else in the in the room
is going to
so at this point
um can I open it up for debate I know
councilor hangs you indicated you wanted
to speak if I've you've been very
patient
um thank you
hmm
thank you chair
um
I I didn't go on the site visit but I am
familiar with the site from previous
visits there so you know that's that's
where I'm coming from
um much of what I was going to say that
you've just outlined yourself I mean I'm
coming from the the fact that it is in
the local plan there was that process
there was the examination in public so
it was all agreed and what we're looking
at here is just really the the detail of
what the uh what the scheme now is I I
Echo your point about you know
disappointment with some aspects of it
but I fully
um accept the explanation that's been
given by the officers to where we have
fallen short in certain areas
um I take it that the three houses in
the Northwest
um which are in paragraph 356 and
talking about amending the scheme and I
think that's in condition 11. so if that
is giving sufficient term protection to
the fact that that will have to happen
before the approval meets all of its
conditions then I can see no reason
other than to go along with the
recommendation thank you
thank you councilor
anyone else wanted to speak councilor
Dewhurst thank you
thank you chair I've got two questions
and two comments really
um first comment is I'm really pleased
to see the conditions about Hedgehog
highways back boxes bird boxes roses
smiling there
and I think that's really good however
at 5.4 I noticed that the EA is
um
particularly concerned about water bowls
and the adverse impact on them and these
are a a mammal which is on the UK red
list of extremely endangered uh mammals
and it it raises the issue of water
bowls but I can't see anything else in
the
um in in the proposals and and what we
might be doing to mitigate the impact on
these protected mammals
um the next thing
um is about
um
the Bungalows there's an awful lot
mentioned in here about the Bungalows
and that being sort of a a positive
thing
um towards the affordable housing
element and and as a sort of consequence
we should sort of look kindly on this
very low uh number of affordable houses
percentage of affordable houses because
we're putting bungalows in there but in
my part of the world Bungalows are
actually a premium in terms of of
selling people are desperate to live in
Bungalows and so I'm not quite sure why
when it came to the viability we we
we're sort of putting Bungalows down as
a negative
um against uh against the the housing
numbers
foreign
ask officers if they could come back on
that sorry for them if you want a bit of
time but
um
come back on the
bowls thank you
we had comments from the environment
agency on this application and on the
bridge application which was submitted
by County which has been approved and as
part of the bridge application
um there was a requirement for a
waterfall strategy
and that included the looking at the
habitat requirements there and habitat
creation Etc so and that has now been
submitted and reviewed by the council's
biodiversity officer and considered
acceptable so it's been dealt with under
the bridge application rather than this
one but my apologies for not covering
that off in the report
um
with the Bungalows it is the
specifically the affordable housing
um disabled Bungalows which are the the
critical
um the critical point they're the
uh when we have affordable housing
delivered we don't often get uh disabled
provision provided to this degree and
for that reason it is given additional
weighting when we look at it
um I don't know if Ross wants to add
anything on that point I just wanted to
to reinforce that in the officer's view
the affordable housing provision that
we've got at the moment is policy
compliant there's a an element in our
policy that says where Target can't be
met and for the Target in the local plan
can't be met in relation to affordable
housing where if that is supported by
independently verified affordable um
expert advice and Analysis then then the
provision uh well whatever level that
might be at is still considered policy
compliance so in our view and we are
numerically at 14 and a bit percent and
the extra weight of the two affordable
rent m43 accessible bungalows uh is
sufficient to tip us up towards the 15
affordable housing provision which is
the level that our independent viability
expert suggested could be supported at
the site
um I accept that sometimes Bungalows are
a premium products and I think the open
market ones probably will sell really
well here but inevitably they take a bit
more land which means that they are more
expensive to build as well so you know
it's not just the sales value is higher
everything that happens in relation to
that Bungalow costs more and I haven't
gone through the viability work with a
fine tooth comb to see what the the
impact of the having bungalows in the
site is and the detail of that analysis
but I'm content with the conclusion that
the provision that we've got here is 15
broadly speaking affordable housing is
policy compliant in these circumstances
thank you thank you Rose
um
any anything you want to come back on
that at all
um cancer do you guys know thank you
councilor hook next then councilor
McGregor councilor pedrick
thank you chair
um yeah I obviously share the
disappointment of others about the
percentage of affordable housing
um I wanted to ask a few questions on
the retirement properties to Mark open
market retirement properties there are
um list it as a sort of condition a
condition too but it just says
retirement properties and I do
understand that these are just a summary
of the conditions and not the full
wording
um but I can't see I think I saw one
line that said the provision on site of
33 Market cell age-restricted units 11
of which are Bungalows
um
are they age restricted in perpetuity
um so will they always be retirement
Properties or is there a possibility
that Bungalows will get converted to
Dormer Bungalows over time and therefore
um you know in all likelihood be
available for just about anybody so
um can I can I just have that
information please
um in terms of the viability explanation
I think
I think it was councilor petherick what
he was after was an explanation of what
are the exceptional costs on this site
that mean that only 15 or 14 or 15
affordable housing can be provided you
know is it the Link Road what what is it
that is the exceptional cost on this
site
um and just as a matter of Interest what
are what is the affordable housing
percentage that was approved on area to
an area four just so that we can see how
it Compares
um in terms of biodiversity I see um
that there was an objection from Devon
Wildlife trust I don't see it dealt with
in any officer comment beyond the DWT
objections and so can we have it
confirmed that there is a 10 term
biodiversity gain for this site and that
that was properly measured because that
is their objection they're saying the
report produced for the site does not
include an Assessor of net gain of
biodiversity so can we have some
information on that in terms of cell
bunting is there a proposed scheme
elsewhere so I understand that
mitigation money is being given but is
there a scheme proposed
um to spend this money or is it just in
a pot to decide what happens to it later
in the day
um
in terms of pre-commencement conditions
I see there are quite a few in relation
to biodiversity and I understand a
pre-commencement condition must be
agreed with the applicant and can I um
have assurance that the applicant has
agreed to all those pre-commencement
conditions
in terms of allotments
um those of us that um the new
developments in Newton Abbott that had
allotments
um I'm not even sure they've still come
forward you know 10 years further down
the line they were just left as areas
with no top soil on whatsoever and one
of the areas didn't even have vehicle
access so in the planning condition can
we ensure that the allotments are left
in a condition in which you could grow
um
produce and that they are accessible by
vehicles and they are actually left that
way by the developer
um and then can I also understand what
the requirement was for a Mugger I see
um there's some
a bit of a conversation around it but I
don't understand there there was
obviously a requirement for it which was
then
um rescinded for some reason so can I
just understand that
um and I agree that we should be looking
for social rent I mean I hope in some of
what we're saying now across the the
room can be incorporated in conditions
um and I presume that Reserve matters
applications will have to come in and
that those um as a sort of Safeguard
those could also be called back to
committee if there's anything further
down the line that you know local
members are not happy with
um and I think we have diligent local
members in that Ward that would come
back um so presumably there is a scope
to come back if further down the line
um they're not happy with some of the
reserve matters that come forward but if
we can have some clarification on the
matters I raise thank you
thank you very much councilor hook do
you want some time officers to to look
at those points
okay if you want to
make your reply
so the retirement properties the
obligation in there would be that they
are age-restricted that is usually over
55s
um and that we'd expect that to be in
perpetuity there's also a proposed
condition to remove permitted
development rights for Upward extensions
to ensure that they remain as Bungalows
so that would mean that if somebody did
want to build upwards they would need to
submit a planning application which
would be considered on its own merits at
that time
um
in terms of the abnormals on the site
um there was some down there for the
demolition site clearance
um under build foundations so to do with
drainage and
um works on there they are set out in
the
um
in the viability report assessment
uh in terms of the affordable on the
other sites
um
this area two so area two has 17.5
percent
and area 4 had
it was reduced it was there was
viability work on that one as well
um with areas three and four their
viability was considered as part of the
securing of the hip funding so obviously
that kind of acknowledges there is
difficulty delivering here
um
area Falls was further reduced because
they had a vacant building credit
um what the
I won't say 14 before that but double
check the provision at area 4 was
similar so all three have ended up with
a relatively you know same ballpark less
than 20 delivered on site um for the
affordable housing what what the precise
numbers are I've managed to pull up one
but I haven't pulled up the other I
think I want to say it was 19 reduced
down to 12 for area four but it's it's
of that order
um across the whole of the site so
obviously substantial difficulties with
building including as a consequence of
the ground conditions that we've been
talking about
uh the interview allotments there is
parking and access shown within the
drawings
um as I said previously the management
of that and we just expect specification
to be required as part of the planning
obligations to make sure that it is
delivered and delivered in an
appropriate way the the mugger was a
requirement in the SPD and it is not
being proposed on the site it's
something that has been discussed with
the applicant
um but their position is that there
isn't sufficient space to deliver it
planning planning is always a balance of
the different matters and yes this
wouldn't deliver them a Mugger however
overall officers recommending approval
as they think that the benefits of the
scheme outweigh the the lack of the
mother with this one this is a full
application so there wouldn't be any
reserve matters submissions coming
forward
the other sites here have been developed
under the outline Reserve matters and
the reserve matters for area two are
likely to come to committee at some
point in the next
couple of months
um but for this one it is a full
application
for the development
I'm not sure there's a couple more that
I wrote down and I wrote down cell
buntings yeah and so members may recall
uh full Council agreed to support the
rspb with funding for a new Reserve at
Ash Hill and that proposal I think was
forward funded including threesome
borrowing I can't remember who who
borrowed what but um I would expect that
contribution from here would go to
support the Ash Hill Reserve which is uh
between Bishop Stanton and timmouth so
there is an identified forward-funded
project that that was held hunting and
contributions can go towards and members
have also talked about the social rent
versus affordable rent the viability
assessment has been undertaken on the
basis of affordable rent and that is
then the provision that that's currently
included in in the 106 and in the
viability if we were to request social
rent then that would have a further
impact on the number of units that we
would be able to provide and the last
one that I think was raised was around
the 10 percent by diversity in that gain
which is detailed in the National
planning policy framework as an
aspiration it's not yet
um
part of the uh isn't it's embedded in
the environment act which will come into
Force next November and but it's not
embedded in our local plan and it is not
reasonable for us to insist on 10
biodiversity net gain as it hasn't been
taken into account in terms of the
viability alongside our other planning
policy requirements and Anna do you want
to say something there is something
about offsetting and net gain at this
site in general isn't that and do you
want to pick that one up please
um there is an obligation for
[Music]
um
find it
and so for a biodiversity offsetting
mechanism that is if they don't manage
to
have no net loss on site that is as per
area area two and area four so that's
similar obligations and as Ross said the
biodiversity net gain 10
doesn't actually come in until next
November
probably that's the date that's been
forecast so obviously we're gearing up
to that change and as we move forward
we'll expect that to be delivered
but with this site it is not considered
to be a local plan requirement for the
delivery here
okay
anything you'd like to come back on that
councilor hook I know there's other
people who want to speak
thank you so you're
um proposing to say no net loss of
biodiversity have you measured the what
what have they measured
um the biodiversity of the site before
um
well the current biodiversity of the
site so that you can be assured of that
so there will have been an ecological
impact assessment undertaken as part of
the environmental statement that was
required for the development of this
site so that would give us a full
Baseline in terms of both of habitat and
uh
um flora and fauna that were present on
the site whether or not that is in the
in uh the uh an offsetting Matrix at the
moment to establish the number of
credits and units that there are on site
I don't know but that would be what we
would build into this mechanism and
Matrix if they're not able to
deliver no net loss then
um we would expect that to be
compensated for Via other mechanisms but
they're given the size of the size and
the amount of green infrastructure that
we've got around its fringes I would
hope that we would be able to achieve no
net loss on site and therefore the the
mechanism itself wouldn't wouldn't come
in but Anna Do you want to
the Baseline is including the ecological
impact assessment which is part of the
um environment the environmental
statement submitted with this
um with this application so the Baseline
will be set out in there
I'm not sure that we have had a
calculation on The Matrix but then
that's not something that was required
um when this application was submitted
and that's where we're at
it's putting the microphone on I think
that's where we're at with that okay
um
councilor McGregor raise your hand
please oh have you already got a
microphone I do thank you thank you
chair
um I think
um councilor hook meant all an audit of
the biodiversity on on site
um which is something we've been pushing
for for quite some time is a better
understanding what is actually on site
environmental impact assessments a much
too broad-ranging to actually give us an
idea of what the Dubai diversity is on
site currently
um Coming specifically to the mugger I
mean that's a really good point I think
to kind of point out that this is going
to be a very very large
um development when it's completed
1200 houses or 800 houses I think and
not having a Mugger
uh either allocated to this site or
reallocated to another site then removes
um cultural capital from residents
within the development overall and I
think it is a sad indictment that we're
not really pushing for a Mugger there
the highways Authority on 5.37 note that
there is no safe and suitable access
across the site
from the public Highway and they have
called country to paragraph 110 of the
nppf 2021.
and while the highway Authority has no
in-princible objection to the access
identified through this process further
details are required as to this access
strategy before a recommendation can be
made
as to whether this is suitable or not
um so I don't think that they have
agreed that it's acceptable
and I don't know
whether they're objecting or or agreeing
while an in-principle object no in
principle objection stands
final decision hasn't been made on that
so that that is a little bit of a
concern
on 5.52
um
Natural England specifically say
permission should not be granted until
such time as the implementation of these
measures has been secured can I have a
guarantee from the planning officers
that the points raised in 5.52 have
actually been met prior to today's
decision making process just yeah just
for Clarity on that one to come in
straight away and for the complete
avoidance of Doubt what that means is
that we secure the money through the
section 106 agreement so we won't Grant
planning permission until the section
106 agreement has been signed the
section 106 agreement includes the
funding for the southeast Devon
mitigation strategy works and there are
also the other elements of this the
mitigation strategy that are funded
through cell and so that's an ongoing
rolling program
um but first priority is given in
spending oursel to ensuring that that we
are not held up from granting plan
information as a consequence of any um
Natural England requirements so that
that that is simply saying this need to
go in a 106 agreement to make sure that
you get the money so that we can make
sure that that mitigation is delivered
so yeah absolutely that's in there and
is Devin wild wildlife trust objections
still outstanding as not met
Devin Wildlife trust aren't a statutory
Consulting so they whilst we take into
account what they say in our
consideration we give greater weight to
our internal biodiversity consultation
responses and also to the comments that
come through from bodies such as Natural
England and and the environment agency
so we may not have gone back out to
Devon Wildlife trust to see whether or
not what we have now would meet all of
their requirements so if they haven't
responded it doesn't mean that we
haven't addressed their comments it just
means we may not have asked them the
question again but if they're seeking 10
net gain and that's not being delivered
here as we've set out because it's not
part of our policy approach then yes
their their objection will still be in
place
okay thank you
thank you councilor McGregor I've got
councilor pedrick and then councilor
duhurst I'll take a few over there for
me because I've got some paperwork to
refer to which I've dropped once and got
sorted out again absolutely fine
thank you just try to go through this in
a logical sequence
um
I've I had some points that require
clarification earlier and I have spoken
to the officers
um and asked about my first point was
about the Barton surgery
um for for every new dwelling that was
constructed on this development the
Barton surgery would receive 400 pounds
which is equivalent to 800 80 000 pounds
but I understand that if they'd require
additional funding then they can apply
to us for sale money if they want to
build an extension or something along
those lines so that I feel has been
resolved I also asked about the this is
this is in the recommendations this is
item 13.
um there's the library and the Red Rock
Center the Red Rock Center is a building
on the outskirts of the Town that's
primarily a youth club but it's also
used for educational needs for for
children that perhaps have had
difficulty in sort of fitting into other
other education facilities and there's
quite a staggering amount and actually
727 pounds per dwelling which is going
to be 146 000 pounds so from this from
this development and similar amounts
from the other developments as well but
the officers have advised that this is
um I'm going to ask them to perhaps
repeat that again please because I'm
sorry that went over the top of my head
but that was a concern that I had as
well
um also the the NHS trust initially
asked for 191 000 pounds uh but they
were told no you're not going to do that
because you knew this was coming you
knew 10 years ago we were going to build
all these houses so now's not the time
to ask 191 000 pounds but if indeed they
could identify a justifiable need then
they could come to teambridge for for
sale money as well
um because the NHS trust they've
submitted a 33-page document I only
printed off three pages of it but in the
last couple of paragraphs they mentioned
um without the requested contribution
we we will still provide Health Care to
all the new residents and development
its ability to support health and
well-being for everyone providing Health
Quality services are sustainable
NHS switch will be will be compromised
so what they're saying is if they don't
get the money then the services are
going to be compromised but they need to
come to us teambridge if they require
more money
um a couple of our counselors have
already mentioned about the the Elm
Grove Road and the new stretch of
highway
um
it's got some notes here if I remember
correctly
um
I attended a County Council briefing on
on the new Link Road I mean it sounds as
though it's going to make a wonderful
difference to the flow of traffic
through dawlish and potentially it could
do but I attended the briefing and the
first thing I asked was about the yellow
lines and that's been mentioned twice
earlier and but so no we're not going to
Yellow Line it but know that when you
see the details of the plan I think
there is a greater need to do that now
the road is six meters wide that's not
very wide at all
um dawlish has a stretch of highway
which could be Loosely described as a
link Road and that's known as John Nash
Drive I appreciate that most of the
members won't know where John Nash Drive
is but that's about nine meters wide and
that was built to to serve a new
development which is in excess of 200
houses out of those 200 houses only
about three actually front onto that
road most of them sort of park around
the back and so on and yet
dozens and dozens of residents we'll
park along that road not a major problem
because it's nine meters wide and
there's still enough room for two
vehicles to pass
but a six meter wide road if residents
Park on it it's going to create a lot of
problems now it's going to also be used
as a bus route
double deckers possibly well the double
decker is 2.5 meters wide but then if
you include Wing mirrors as well which
all all vehicles have that will increase
it to about 2.75 meters wide so they're
going to take up most of the width of
the carriageway in One Direction if a
bus comes the other way they're going to
get awfully close to actually colliding
so the the total width of these vehicles
as I say is 2.8 so so buses and lorries
passing no lorries tend to have Wing
mirrors that extend even further than
150 millimeters I've noticed that today
um and there have been cases where
pedestrians have been injured on
Pavements because they've been struck
with these mirrors that overhang
Pavements
um
the the Pavements through this site some
will have grass verges in between the
highway and and the pavement but not not
all of them will do and I have real
grave concerns about that now I've I was
one of the members that was present when
this plan was first voted and I voted it
through I have no real objections to
this development but I have grave
concerns about the highway and I feel
possibly inclined to abstain from voting
on this one
the highways department is saying well
we know there's going to be problems but
what we can do is we can we can alter
the flower traffic no no once again
members won't be familiar with the word
Elm Grove Road but Elm Grove Road is
quite a busy road at the moment it links
the number of developments to the town
but what county is suggesting now to to
ease the flower traffic on Elm Grove
Road is to restrict traffic the wanting
to turn right from the excellent
Direction
so that means that the traffic has to go
somewhere else so it will be using
possibly the whole stretch of this so I
mentioned this before but we we already
have a nightmare on Elm Grove Road and I
think it's going to get even worse
ultimately County May well end up by
signalizing the this Junction I mean it
should have been done some years ago
quite frankly but they're going to wait
and see what happens when they alter the
traffic flow and not allow traffic to
turn right into Elm Grove Road so
anybody coming from Exeter that wants to
exercise access probably one of the 2000
dwellings is either going to have to
follow the Link Road or go up
um I'm sorry the name of the road
Escapes Me Now where the sports center
is
Sandy Lane good afternoon accessor Sandy
Lane which is Elaine it's Sandy Lane
it's not very wide so you're going to
get hundreds if not thousands of
vehicles going up there so I have real
concerns about that
and there's one other question if I may
please friend I've got a question here
5.46 the County Council will also
require a contribution towards club car
vehicles
30 000 pounds each times two so what
what are club car vehicles please
we've spoken about education and um if
if there is a child that has special
needs and I can recall when I was a
governor at starcross that this can
impact quite heavily on a school's
budget uh if a child wants to become a
pupil there because they have to make
certain adaptions to to the premises and
I recall it star-cross it was necessary
to install a special toilet and changing
room which costs a lot of money but I
see that there is an allowance will be a
there's a standard rate available for
schools to claim if they have one of
these patients and it's 89 000 pounds
which seems to me to be quite reasonable
um but then I I also then query well how
what happens about this well it's not
the development that play for this pay
for this not directly it's from sill
money so if a school has a need for an
sen patient and need this development
will create possibly 1.6 then they the
the applicants sorry the schools can
actually apply to Cambridge for sale
money
I think that's everything I've just got
to say one question on what are Club
Vehicles please thank you
it's always reach already reaching for
the mic I think Anna so thank you
um so cup class are things like coca
where you have
um shared access to Vehicles rather than
individual ownership
um
there is a proposal for a travel plan
um for this
for this development
um
that would include any requirement like
that but there's not a specific
obligation for the delivery of a uh car
club vehicles
the
in terms of the contributions I think I
said before that there is an adopted SPD
for this site that looked at the
infrastructure requirements and as part
of that it included library and Red Rock
Center contributions and the Barton
surgery contributions so they're all
included within that the
following the highways comments we did
have additional information submitted
and there have been further discussions
with highways which is reflecting a
paragraph 3.34 where they have no
objection
subject to the construction traffic
coming from the north
which would be dealt with through the
approval of a construction Environmental
Management plan
in terms of the education contributions
then that is expected to come through
sell payments and
uh
obviously this development will be still
liable and that will be a sizeable
amount of
um it's going to be north of two million
pounds
with the with the link crew through the
site the SPD
um required a carriage weight six meters
wide to allow for that plus access
through there
um I think as we've previously said that
the yellow material lines would be
something that that the local highways
Authority could look at later date but
there's no evidence before us at this
stage that it would be a requirement of
this application and we've had no
comments from the highways Authority
that would indicate that that would be
um
necessary
okay
um thank you for that we'll move on with
the next requested speaker
um councilor Dewhurst you wanted to come
back
you had to put your hand up
thank you chair
um just in in terms of what we've been
talking about with regards to
environmental impact and monitoring and
the like I notice on uh condition 15
that we have a condition to survey trees
and buildings for roosting bats and
nesting Birds prior to the works
can I ask what happens to that and and
is it just a sort of a list which then
one can say well you know we've lost
them or or is this something that we
actually do something about uh to ensure
that that we don't lose them but at the
end of it we actually have at least the
same number or more thank you
um
roosting bats nesting Birds both
protected by law so if during that
survey and there were bats or Birds
found then that would need to be dealt
with through appropriate licensing
system with natural England
and through the there is requirements
obviously for the detailed design of the
bat and bird mitigation and
um the through the lamp and the
biodiversity
um the other conditions that are there
but if there is a the conditions there
so that you know when when they come to
it she demolish the building on site
that if there are nesting birds in there
that they just
um
that they check to make sure there
aren't any beforehand and if there are
then as I said there are legal
Protections in place for those
okay thank you you wanted to quickly
come back on on that cancer do you have
yes please chair thank you of course if
they did the survey you know now they
wouldn't find any nesting birds so it is
that is is this time
limited or or you know when when will
the survey be done
please
you're about to chop down a tree you
don't do it before you check that
whether or knock down a building you
don't do that before you've checked if
there's anything nesting or roosting in
it so it's about that when you do the
works because if you then need to put in
place additional mitigation that hasn't
been captured by the other conditions
you can you can do that with with the
knowledge or or you might need to
reprogram your site and your site Works
to allow those birds to to complete
their nesting season before the tree is
is or structure is is removed so it's
about uh identifying whether there is a
need for any additional mitigation
there's a consequence of the specific
habits of specific creatures as opposed
to the generic approach that we take to
the generic site-wide planning so it's
dealing with those hyper local issues
and that you only know about there's no
like you say there's no point in doing a
survey now
if they're gonna the work's gonna
commence next summer but equally there's
not much point in doing a survey next
summer if the works aren't going to
start for another 12 months so we want
to make sure we've got up-to-date
information about the actual usage
habits of actual
um
bats and birds as opposed to the generic
we know this site is used by
um bats and birds around around its
fringes we can then make sure that that
better mitigation is put in place
thank you thank you for that um I have
councilor hook who'd like to come in and
then councilor McGregor councilor
Bradford
thank you chair
um back to biodiversity
um I don't think I'm incorrect to say
that we have conditioned biodiversity
net gain of 10 on other major
applications
um so I I would like to add it in
um as a condition
um and the use of the Matrix and this is
actually quite a recent application
um 2021 it's not as if it's been kicking
around for years and
um don't we have the environment act
2021 hasn't that been through all stages
of Parliament that now requires that 10
net gain so you know irrespective I I
think we've done it on other major
applications and I would like to add it
in here in terms of the road
um I think it is a careful Balancing Act
between designing a road that isn't
going to encourage high traffic speeds
so the wider you build the road the
higher the traffic speeds are likely to
be and just um because it's a link grow
doesn't mean to say that we want um
traffic to be traveling at speed through
a residential area so I think it is a
careful Balancing Act and I think it is
potentially sensible to see how it
operates and then if there's need for
double yellows in a particular location
but then that's taken forward but if the
road isn't adopted that would be
impossible so is it proposed that the
road is adopted early on because
um thinking of roads in Hill Park even
the May main link roads that will
potentially ultimately be link roads
they're still not adopted so you
couldn't have double yellows on them so
is is it proposed that it would be
adopted very early on in the development
so that was two points there
thank you are you able to come back on
so in terms of the road
um Devon County Council are proposing to
construct that and they'll also be doing
that on the basis that they'll take it
to an adoptable standard and and um
with the intention for it to be adopted
and certainly obviously they would
expect there to be in the highways
agreements
um
the requirement for it to be public
successful if you've been spending
public money on the delivery of it
planning cannot require the adoption of
roads it's previously gone through the
courts and I don't know if Ros wants to
add anything on that but it's been
previously held that planning cannot
require
the adoption it can only require the
roads are delivered up to an appropriate
standard
in terms of biodiversity net gain
probably in terms of other sites might
leave that one down to Ross to answer
the 10 percent is due to become law in
November
next year
I think there may need to be additional
act additional legislation for that to
come through I'm not sure if that's gone
through yet
thank you Anna and
so the way that our local plan is
structured at the moment is that we seek
no net loss of biodiversity on our
allocated sites and if we're approving
development on
unallocated sites then we seek and
biodiversity net gain and so I'd cut I
can't think of an example where we have
requested 10 that game but if we have it
may have been as an example on and I've
completely forgotten the name of the
site uh Barry Knowles
um which was an unallocated site where
there were other material considerations
that weighed in their balance in our
decision-making process there so
um if you're if we were allowing
something that's outside the local plan
then we expect to see material benefits
of which no uh net gain would be won and
the planners currently structured is for
no net loss we are moving towards a
position of expecting net gain and but
that isn't embedded in our local plan at
the moment it is becoming
uh the weight to be given to the
biodiversity net gain Provisions
compared to the weight to be given to
our local plan is changing all the time
as we move towards that November 23 date
at the moment we don't have
um an established way to calculate it
from Natural England we are in
consultation and in draft mode with them
the offsetting Matrix matrices have not
been published in their final form yet
so everything that we do is is still
slightly
um smallly experimental you know we
understand the principle of the
offsetting mechanisms that will be used
to
um
ascribe units to different types of
habitat based on the amount and the
quality of that habitat and then and
consider how Replacements would match up
and but that is not yet something that's
been published in its final form so we
are still uh on a journey towards that
November 23 date so at the moment I
don't think it would be reasonable for
us to impose a condition requiring 10
net gain and if we did that I think we
would be
um we would run the risk of there being
additional impacts on viability of
development here I think the the
framework that we've got the conditions
that we've got around the um
environmental impact assessment and the
the no net loss Provisions that are
built in the offsetting mechanism that
is built into the the decision framework
that we've set out for you today
um is the reasonable place that we can
take it to
um
but obviously we'll that's that's uh Our
advice
thank you for that um I have councilor
McGregor wanted to come back and then
counselor Bradford
thank you chair
um just coming back briefly to the
discussion on
affordable housing I seem to recall very
early on in the current administration's
meetings that we discussed the site in
dawlish that originally had been planned
at 17 reduced to 11 and actually
delivered four percent affordable
housing can we just have an absolute
commitment that we will not
Retreat to those kind of levels of
numbers
um in terms of
um councilor John federick's point about
the NHS I think it's worth pointing out
that when the NHS are now coming asking
for money they're not just coming and
asking for money because they think they
can get money out of a site
funding for the NHS has materially
reduced compared to the cost of living
increases and inflation over the last 10
to 12 years simply because of economic
climates Etc also government policy but
it is important that we we recognize
that the NHS are asking for a reason and
we do not want to see Services
compromised particularly for new
residents coming into an area
and new developments and I think it's
important that perhaps we have one eye
on speaking to developers to encourage
them to make a contribution if they can
uh thank you very much chair
thank you
um
I don't think there's anything to to any
points to make on that but we from that
point of view councilor Bradford you
wanted to have a say
thank you
um thank you Jeff I've just got a couple
of questions regarding
um the Devon Wildlife Trust on I'm not
clear on where we are with that
and the other question is how does a
budget protection plan work please
foreign
so in terms of the badger protection
plan like we have the waterfall strategy
for the bridge application we'd expect
details of that so the detailed scheme
to be submitted and approved that would
be considered by our bed firstly
officers at the appropriate stage which
would be prior to the commencement of
the relevant phase of the development so
we wouldn't necessarily have something
that was site-wide if it only impacts on
a smaller area so it's in terms of the
Devon Wildlife trust comments um I think
Roz can cover this earlier that
the in terms of the 10 biodiversity net
gain
um
and also in terms of that that we have
the biodiversity comments from our own
officer and from Natural England as well
um who are the obviously the relevant
statutory Authority in terms of of this
site
I don't know Ross would you like to add
anything to them
no okay Roz you already went through
through all that I know from that point
of view okay where are we then I don't
have any more speakers at the moment
um I don't know if there are any other
points that members want to stand
um on or
confirmed but we are where we are
what our members minded to do cancer
Dewhurst
thank you
chair sorry for clarity I just wanted to
to come in because we did an update our
recommendation
um at the beginning of the meeting and
verbally
um I can't remember what change we made
sorry Anna so we've got the ass set out
in the update sheet which makes it clear
what the percentage of affordable
housing is and then we added in the
extra condition about the link to area
five so making sure we've got the link
into area five so we've got the main
report and then the update report which
adjusts the affordable housing and our
recommendation is that we include the
additional Link Road so I just wanted to
make sure that members were aware of
that additional condition thank you for
that Clarity so that is not as an
amendment it's a it's a yeah so
counselor do you host do you content
with your
um thank you okay so your your content
with taking that into consideration
thank you
so as as set out with
um the additional as specified thank you
Council Haynes
thank you councilor Haynes
any other points or
um I don't think we we've kind of had a
good debate from that point of view I
think we know where we are so can I ask
um I think it's
um Chris you're going to be taking us
through a roll call vote so can I ask us
to go to the vote please on this item
thank you chair councilor Bradford
councilor con it
counselor Cox
councilor Dewhurst
councilor Haynes
councilor Jackie hook
councilor Jeffrey
councilor McGregor
councilor Brad Council Goodman Bradbury
four
and councilor John Patrick
[Music]
chair that's uh five four one against
and uh four extensions has carried
okay so we will move on to
um the next item major decision summary
I don't think we have a
any items on that
um
but we do have the appeal decisions
reached and Rose if I could ask you to
speak to that please
thank you chair um I don't think there's
anything of particular note on these um
it will come forward next month and the
appeal in relation to area five which we
um
surprisingly didn't actually come up in
our conversation today was was dismissed
because of the access difficulties
offset Mason Lane largely as well as
other concerns relating to biodiversity
so that'll be on next month's list but I
don't think that the
um applications that are that or the
appeal decisions that are on the list
today raise any particular issues of um
you know of note although having said
that I have just spotted 34 Saint Mary's
Road in tinmouth which is the balcony
decision where members overturned and
offers a recommendation to accrue and
the appeal was dismissed so members
decision there was upheld
um in relation to the the overlooking
impacts of that larger balcony so that
one is worth noting
thank you
um well that brings us to the end of the
meeting thank you for your attention at
this time and
yeah close that formally close the
meeting
at 11 31.